بحسب الخبراء هناك 16 نوعا من الاطعمه
تدعم فقدان الوزن وتعزز صحه العامه نذكر
ابرزها سريعا اول هالبروتين الخالي من
الدهون اذ يعطي احساسا بالشبع ويقلل
الرغبه في تناول الطعام كذلك هو الحال مع
البروتينات النباتيه كالبقوليات التي لها
نفس الفوائد البيض فهو يحتوي على جميع
الفيتامينات الاساسيه الى جانب الكونه
مصدر البروتيني كامل الخضروات بجميع
انواعها خاصه الداكنه منها وايضا
الافوكادو الغني بالدهون الصحيه التفاح
الغني بمضادات الاكسده وكذلك هو الحال مع
التوت المكسرات والبذور فهي مصدر جيد
للالياف والدهون الصحيه والبروتين وبذور
الشيا التي تمنع الافراط في تناول الطعام
سمك السلمان الغني بالاوميجا 3 والروبيان
الذي يقلل من الشهيه حبوب الترمس والشوفان
الخام مهمان لازاله الدهون العنيده
المخزنه حول الخصر لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانس انيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات